you know I'm very torn about them I you
know I have to confess I did get an MFA
from Columbia University and I can't say
that I regret it exactly I didn't have a
bad time I had some interesting teachers
I'm still in touch with one of them and
I you know we've become friends I am
still friends with some of the students
that I met at Columbia my very best
friend I'm not at that program so it's a
little mystifying why my immediate
impulse is to dis MFA programs but I
sometimes feel in retrospect that I
should have gotten a proper education in
something like history something
substantive if if I'm going to be honest
what I really needed in my early 20s was
an audience and I wasn't developed
enough as a writer to be publishing so I
couldn't achieve that audience through
you know getting short stories in The
New Yorker frankly at this point of time
I'm still not getting short stories in
the New Yorker I'm working on it
so it was it was not a dumb thing for me
to do and therefore I can't really tell
other people who are in a similar
situation and have a similar need to you
know have people read their work that
that they shouldn't do it but it it does
have a kind of indulgent middle-class
Gestalt
the grim truth is that most people who
get MFA's will not go on to be
professional writers and therefore when
I've been on the other side of it and
occasionally taught creative writing I
felt a little bit guilty because so many
of the people that you know you should
be encouraging there's no point to it if
you're not encouraging or not gonna make
and and I think that's true across the
board in the arts I mean my husband's a
jazz drummer and he has the same sense
of queasiness about teaching jazz
drumming there's more of a career in
teaching jazz then there isn't playing
it right now and so at at the very best
what most of his students are going to
go on to become jazz instructors so
there's something a little corrupt in
that something unwholesome and I share
his discomfort in participating in it